on va refaire un point sur les
déclarations de vladimir poutine avec
jean didier revoir bonjour jean didier
vous êtes à moscou pour france 24 les
russes fonce donc sur sur kiev mais le
kremlin se dit prêt à revenir à la table
des négociations avec les ukrainiens et
en même temps vladimir poutine appelle
l'armée ukrainienne a renversé le
pouvoir
écouter c'est tout le paradoxe a
effectivement valencia cet après-midi
dans une ouverture en se disant qu'ils
en disant qu'il était prêt à négocier a
parlé d'une finlandisation de l'ukraine
à savoir doter l'ukraine du statut d'
état neutre qui était une des exigences
de la réussite qui tient cher au coeur
de la demi-heure poutine visiblement
mais dans le même temps il ya on voit
aussi vous l'avez dit que le blazer
poutine a appelle l'armée ukrainienne à
la désobéissance estimant qu'il serait
plus simple de négocier directement
entre moscou et l'armée plutôt qu'avec
la clique de narcomanes et de néo nazis
qui est aujourd'hui au pouvoir à kiev le
problème de cette position c'est que
après les semaines voire les mois de
négociations menées avec de la lumière
poutine qui exigeait la mise en oeuvre
des accords de minsk pour pouvoir
négocier une désescalade avec l'ukraine
et ses partenaires occidentaux on voit
que tout ces efforts diplomatiques n'ont
servi à rien car depuis hier
effectivement les forces russes bombarde
l'ukraine et la question c'est dans
quelle mesure est ce que cette
proposition
des russes de se rendre à minsk pour
pour éventuellement négocier une
neutralisation de l'ukraine et bien dans
quelle mesure est ce qu'ils sont prêts à
s'engager vraiment sur cette voie pour
l'instant personne ne le sait on a
insisté hier à moscou à quelques
manifestations pour dire non à la guerre
est-ce que d'abord on sait combien de
personnes ont été interpellées est ce
qu'une nouvelle mobilisation a lieu ce
soir alors écoutez ce matin les
différents sites d'information faisait
état d'environ 1800 arrestation on peut
en déduire que d'autres arrestations ont
certainement eu lieu aujourd'hui jeudi
les péchés pas vu les détails exacts
mais ce qu'il faut souligner dans cette
danse est dans cette problématique c'est
que passer un moment de sidération car
les russes s'attendent à une attaque
plutôt ciblé sur le don de bassesse
alentour pas eu une attaque d'ampleur
aussi importantes que celles qu'on
connaît depuis hier et bien plusieurs
d'entre eux se sont mobilisés notamment
des artistes des scientifiques des
représentants du monde des arts et
spectacles ont signé une pétition en
disant qu'il s'opposait à la guerre il
était contre cette guerre vécue n'est
pas revenir poutine et puis aussi plus
courageusement une centaine de
conseillers municipaux de villes comme
moscou saint pétersbourg samara ou
encore veliki novgorod ont eux aussi
signé une tribune comme quoi ils
s'opposent à la guerre et et critique la
décision de l'avenir poutine on constate
donc que si la grande majorité des
russes soutient son président comme à
son habitude et bien on voit apparaître
ça et là des noyaux de contestation
reste à savoir si ces noyaux prendront
de l'ampleur car pour l'instant il faut
bien le dire que le quotidien des russes
n'a pas vraiment changé en tout cas des
moscovites ils vivent leur vie comme si
de rien n'était avec peut-être une
tendance accrue à vérifier les
informations sur un téléphone portable
merci beaucoup j'en dis dire voir en
direct de moscou pour france 24